last month during the holidays we had a
very special visitor here she had a huge
2023 including a number one song a
number one album plus no big deal she's
nominated for six Grammys I'm talking
about Olivia Rodrigo we had a lot to
chat about a lot both girls both
musicians there's a lot there y'all and
we couldn't fit it all into the first
show because of talk a lot so she so
today I present to you a Kelly extra
here's more of our conversation um this
is the one and only Olivia
Rodrigo we I love the Twilight series I
also love hunger games which you got to
do the the credit side that's incredible
do you I I appreciate writing for
something other than just my records I
think it's kind of fun and different you
love it fun yeah I love writing for
something that's not just like me
writing from my heart like a diary sort
of it's sometimes really nice to stretch
yourself as a writer and at had the best
time and I love the movie I was so
inspired by the character of of of Lucy
gray and um so yeah it was it was a lot
of fun and I went to the premiere the
other day and it was so fun I felt very
glamorous at the premiere was that your
first premiere one of my it was like the
first uh movie premiere that I went to
that I was like kind of like a part of a
part of it yeah and it was so special
and movie's doing well and I'm just so
happy for everyone involved it was such
an honor to be a tiny tiny little part
of it I know you feel like I my we have
something com that literally the first
film I was ever part of uh was Love
Actually which is like one of my
favorite things and I had a song on
there but I was at the I felt like I
don't know if you you're young have you
seen pretty woman I have seen Pretty
Woman yes so you know when she walks in
the store and they're like you don't
belong here that's how I felt I had to
go after Kira nightly on the red carpet
and I was like why am I here I was like
I felt so awkward do you get awkward in
those environments I do super I mean
being on a red carpet is like the most
and your smile starts to shake yeah I
know you're like shaking on you're so
scared yeah your smile starts cuz you're
smiling so much and you're like well I
don't want to look like I have a twitch
yeah but yeah it's unfortunate yeah it's
anxiety and do I I had a similar
experience I think one time I went on a
red carpet after Johnny Depp when I was
really young I was like you guys like no
just don't even just take just take his
picture like dude I had to go after
Shakira once too and I was like
well no one knows I'm here I was like I
don't know I'm here I'm watching her I
was like anyway it's it's an interesting
thing I think people think because
you're in the public eye that you're
always comfortable in all this
environments but no red carpets are like
the enemy for me that's why you don't
see me on them um I'm like I got old
enough to be like no anyway we we have
something in common I know you're by but
you recently moved to New York as well
right me too I love it what's your
favorite part o i mean you have to give
me all the recommendations I haven't
been here long but I just love like
walking around like I love putting my
earbuds in and walking around and
listening to music and listening to
podcast and feeling you can just kind of
like blend into the city you know it's
so fun I know I walk around so much here
which is so good for you first of all
but also get our steps in it's get your
steps in and also it's just good for
your emotional health to get outside
yeah we have something else in common
too so I recently got to sing with
atanas who's one of my heroes mine too
I'm so proud of you because you're 20 so
I'm
like this is I'm sure someone has it
somewhere but when sour came out I was
like oh this chick is like the new
Atlanta like for her generation your
Atlanta your generation like it's like
it was that kind of impact of of the and
you're young to be a fan of hers oh my
gosh I love do you have the coolest mom
ever or something I do have the coolest
mom ever I feel like your kids probably
say this I was going to say I don't know
they do right now they're getting close
to being over me but yes they'll come
back around try and slide really good
music in yeah I bet is that how you know
atena um I think so I mean I I remember
hearing like you ought to know on the
radio when I was like 12 years old and
being like what is oh my God she can say
that line about the theater like exactly
that's
insane and so just I fell in love with
her and um yeah it was so nice I I sang
a song with her at one of my concerts
saying you know you know which is crazy
can you believe that I got to do it on
this show and I died oh my God this is
insane she's the reason why I'm a writer
yeah like I'm a i a singer for many
different artists including her but like
she is one of the main reasons why I'm a
songwriter cuz I was like oh man I can
funnel this and it was so helpful like
you don't realize the impact you know
you make as an artist on people and she
just impacted so many completely yeah
for different Generations yeah that's an
amazing all right everybody Olivia six
time gy nominated album dut and her H
sing can't catch me now from The Hunger
Games The Ballad of song birds and
snakes are available wherever you get
your music plus are sold out worldwide
Arena tour kicks off next month we'll be
right back with what I'm
[Music]
[Applause]
liking thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home